six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go next to our caller
from the six one six
area code caller from six one six
introduce yourself and go right ahead
six one six are you there yeah you're
there can you hear me oh I didn't even
know I was on uh I was wondering do you
personally think that Donald Trump
rooted with Russia like just your
personal thought as an individual feel
like that that Trump personally was like
talking to Putin and setting things up
yeah like do you think Putin installed
some guy who doesn't know what he's
doing in our government and now he's
just here well hold on that that's two
different let's take them one at a time
if that's okay with you okay all right
question one is do I think Trump was
directly involved in coordination with
Russian agents I think the answer is
probably no I think that Trump was aware
that his campaign was talking to Russian
actors but I think the likelihood of
Rumph personally coordinating and
anything is probably close to zero not a
good beer okay
second part is do I believe that Russia
installed Trump no not in a literal
sense Russia clearly had an interest in
Trump being the Republican nominee from
a pretty early moment in the primary
once he became the nominee Russia
clearly had a preference for Trump over
Hillary Clinton and they had a number of
different tools at their disposal to
help Trump right that includes the
coordinated the hacking that was done
the release of the documents coming from
those hacks being beneficial to Donald
Trump and detrimental to Hillary Clinton
the dangling of business offers and all
sorts of different stuff right so
there's a lot of different ways but if
you're asking me did Russia literally
install Trump I don't think that's
language that I'd be ready to use at
this point that's fair to say yeah I
have another question okay have you ever
played out of who won no I haven't even
heard of it what is it not up for one
that's pretty much world war one it's
real fun all right it's a video game
yeah just wondering if you ever try to
know what platform is it on I'm pretty
sure it's on th PC Xbox one and then ps4
pretty sure and you play sure repeat why
would you go you've played it of course
yeah of course good real fun all right
thank you for the call appreciate it a
battle for one there it is
heard it from the for the man himself
today's program is made possible in part
by wink spelled WI and si I like wine
but I don't really know how to select a
bottle of wine and that's what wink does
wink makes it easy to discover great
wines that most importantly you will
like because every month they ship you
wines match to your tastes and
personalized to you now you might be
saying well hold on how do they know
what I will like very good question you
go to their website you go to try wink
comm slash Pakman and you fill out this
very short palate profile quiz they will
ask you questions such as how do you
like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and based on the answers to those and a
few other questions you will get great
wines personalized to you and delivered
right to your door as you drink more
wine which I know many in our audience
do and you rate more bottles of wine
wink learns and you get even more
personalized delicious wines for next
time no membership fees skip any month
cancel anytime and there's a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so you will not
pay for a bottle you don't like and for
a limited time you can get 20 bucks off
when you go to try wink comm slash
Pakman that's TR y WI and see comm
forward slash Pakman for $20 off check
it out